Let's recap our four major expectations. One, a
time commitment. You need to be sure to set
aside enough time to complete the course. Two, interaction.
We want you to actively engage with us here
by answering the questions as we go through
them. Three, minimal background. You don't need much information.
So just bring yourself, and you'll get through the
course just fine. And four, get and give help.
If you need extra additional resources, be sure to check out the links under
the instructor's notes in the discussion forums.
And as always, help out your fellow
classmates. If you have information that can
help answer a fellow classmate's question, go
to the forums and give it a shot. We could always use another genome guide.